a big marijuana legislation news the
state of Vermont here in the United
States just north of us our friendly
neighbors to the north but not quite as
north as Canada they have finally and
formally legalized marijuana the
governor has signed it into law
this makes Vermont the ninth state to do
so but this was number one signed into
law by Republican Phil Scott but most
interestingly the other eight states
that have legalized marijuana have done
so by a referendum ballot initiative
where the population of the state votes
Vermont did it by legislative decision
the legislature decided this is
something that we're going to do and the
law is going to allow people 21 years of
age and older to legally possess up to
one ounce of marijuana they will also be
allowed to grow to mature plants and for
immature cannabis plants commercial pot
sales will not be allowed and the law is
going to take a fit effect on July 1st
and even though Vermont is a very
liberal state big picture its liberal in
a slightly different way than some other
places like for example because of its
rural nature and low population even
though Vermont is a very liberal or
democratic state we could say they are
much more in favor of gun rights and
guys in Vermont are sort of a different
thing than they are in states with more
densely populated areas yeah that's why
Bernie Sanders who represents Vermont
yeah Senate took a lot of heat from that
that's exactly right Democrats work for
his position on that so Vermont's an
interesting place ninth state to
legalize and that's very very good news
now meanwhile in Europe the entire
country of Greece is working on an
amendment to legalize medical marijuana
next month this is not recreational but
for medicinal uses economically could be
good for Greece Greece certainly needs
some economic help given the troubles
that they've had over the last eight to
ten years even longer you could argue
they expect that somewhere between a
billion and a half and two billion euros
would be invested in the marijuana trade
in the coming months and there are
already Greek Canadian and Israeli
companies interested in getting involved
now this is
clearly going in the right direction if
cigarettes are legal there's really no
justification for illegal marijuana
that's a major double standard you all
know I've been saying this for years but
really to be more economically
stimulative I believe that number one
Vermont should legalize commercial sales
which they're not doing with this bill
and I believe that Greece should go
beyond just medicinal marijuana which is
going to disproportionately benefit
corporations and I think that they need
to go further in order to really benefit
the population at large in the economy
at large yeah that economic point is
interesting if you actually look at a
map of Europe by weed legalization yep
you see that Greece is joining Spain in
the Netherlands mm-hmm in countries that
have legal marijuana or marijuana that's
essentially illegal though I thought
Portugal was well known I think it's
decriminalized there oh it's in all drug
use but Spain similarly has been facing
some economic hardships yes has Greece
yeah I mean go go beyond just
decriminalization and or medicinal
legalization if you want the economic
benefit we've got a lot of early data
from Colorado already about what the
boon has been did their economy and in
the back of my mind every time we hear
about another state doing this it kind
of feels like it's a middle finger to
Jeff sessions jeff sessions as you might
remember used to like the KKK until he
found out that they smoked pot right but
more importantly other than that
personal opinion which is weird he's
been doing everything that he can as
Attorney General to roll back the
liberalisation on cannabis policy and I
hope more states continue to assert
their constitutionally given states
rights and to keep legalizing in the
face of nonsense from Attorney General
Jeff Sessions yes interesting how eight
of the nine states now with legal
marijuana or blue states the only one is
a red one which is Alaska interesting
but not surprising well Republicans are
supposed to be like the don't tread on
me party yes right freedom liberty
states rights and all of that stuff you
know that that only applies when it's
convenient on an issue that they want to
use to raise money like abortion or gay
marriage or whatever they're not really
for that that's just something they say
to raise money anyway good news from
Vermont good news from Greece hopefully
we'll continue to go in that direction